Nick Cannon is stepping in for his
friend Jamie Foxx as host of beat Shazam
Jamie remains hospitalized in Atlanta
more than three weeks after suffering a
mystery medical emergency Nick dropped
hints that this was in the works when he
spoke with Kevin 12 days ago I know he's
doing so much better because
um I'm actually about to do something
special for him uh and doing him a favor
so I know things about I can't really
say what it is well it'll be out there
soon I was reluctant to to go all the
way there but he gave me the blessing so
it's it's a beautiful thing we're going
to Ireland to shoot what that's right
the fox show shoots in Ireland today
Jaime spoke out for the first time
thanking Nick and fans with this post
saying see you all soon the network also
confirmed Kelly Osborne will fill in as
guest DJ and a noun deleted post she
showed off the set where you could hear
Nick being intro
season six premieres May 23rd and today
Steven twitch bosses Widow Allison
Holcomb is breaking her silence and
getting emotional with hodakotb nearly
five months since his heartbreaking
suicide there is no one that saw this
coming no one he wanted to be the strong
one for everyone and I think that was a
little scary for him to think that he
might need to ask for help he really
wanted to be everyone Superman he said
that a lot one of the most magical
humans
and I learned oh I'm sorry Allison will
now take over her late husband's estate
as she raises their three kids without
him they just ask
when is Daddy coming back
and that's a really hard one then it'll
be like a couple weeks later like but
does he come back when he's older like
when daddy's older he'll come back
[Music]